[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá a todos
vamos ver se agora para quem é mais
importante o trabalho para homens ou
mulheres e para quem é mais importante a
dimensão religiosa a dimensão espiritual
para homens ou mulheres
todos nós temos várias dimensões da
nossa vida
algumas mais importantes e outras menos
importantes
essas dimensões têm uma importância
diferente principalmente quando nós
compramos entre si
para mim este é um tema que vencemos na
minha - sempre que eu vivo certa forma
ter aumentado com a dicotomia entre o
trabalho e entre a família entrou fitas
entre a parte social dentre todas as
esferas e dimensões das nossas vidas que
nos exigem muito tempo já depois de
concluir esta esta apresentação
aconteceu mal alguns dias atrás com o
meu filho eu tenho um filho pequeno está
empresários que é o macho e eu estava a
fazer desporto que eu gosto muito
fitness é uma das dimensões mais
importante pra mim esse segundo problema
no meu telemóvel estava o meu ombro
olhe pro hotel é móvel e era minha
mulher estava ligado
entendo o telemóvel e hoje a voz do meu
filho a voz de um garoto de um rapazinho
com três anos de uma voz aguda e que
dizia pá pá pá vai pra casa quando ouvi
isto imediatamente desligou se uma
lâmpada ia ser deus outra desligou
para duff trás que era aquilo mais
importante pra mim naquela altura aquilo
que tinha toda minha energia e toda a
motivação ea cedeu samba da família e de
certa forma fiquei um pouco envergonhado
por não estar com a família
eu penso imenso nestes temas
e este ano com 11 um estudo há em angola
para 2010 a em profissionais trabalharem
em angola com contas de maio muitos de
deus estão aqui presentes e que me
ajudaram a perceber um pouco mais se
estas etnias sã em importantes para
todos e e essas dúvidas todos nós mas
temos nós fizemos um inquérito que teve
mais do que mais respostas do que
aquelas que nós imaginávamos que teria e
conseguimos 2006 respostas entre
profissionais em angola
estas 2006 respostas nós perguntávamos
acho que pedimos às pessoas para dividir
para distribuírem saem fontes por cada
uma de sete dimensões que a família à
parte da comunidade
a parte do negócio da carreira
profissional
a parte social amigos comunidade a saúde
desporto filhas que eu falava pouco à
parte do desenvolvimento pessoal é parte
da espiritualidade e os nossos jovens
1 a 0 e aquilo que mais gostamos de
fazer nós nós pedimos às pessoas para
distribuir 100 pontos de acordo com a
importância que cada uma destas
dimensões têm e concluímos genericamente
no geral que é para o homem quer para
mulheres o trabalho eu mas a dimensão
mais um bronze miller dimensão mais
importante o trabalho é a segunda
dimensão mais importante mas é nós
para além disto perguntamos também às
pessoas como é que estas dimensões
variam de acordo com a sua ida ao
perguntarmos a e w9 conseguimos perceber
que é e importância destas dimensões
varia ao longo do tempo e nós não temos
em família ou trabalho ou os nossos
jovens tão importantes quanto temos 20
anos quando como tempo de 40 quando
temos 50
nós temos sempre a mudar eu o vi nós
somos homens de vanguardistas que estão
em permanente não temos vozes para os
homens a importância da família e varia
de acordo com a idade
nós conseguimos ver a família é é
moderadamente importante quando somos
novos mas tem uma importância que chance
à medida que vamos envelhecendo e a
partir dos 40 anos têm já a níveis muito
próximos dos 30 por cento
por outro lado
o impacto da comunidade do fibra se do
zero é constantes na vida dos homens ao
longo do tempo
há um ligeiro de creche nos próximos 50
anos
mas são três dimensões e cuidado fitas
de lazer que tem a mesma importância ao
longo da vida dos homens no que diz
respeito à parte espiritual e ao
desenvolvimento pessoal
estas respostas são contra intuitiva
nós observamos onde creche da
importância da espiritualidade
à medida que os homens enviassem à fé e
à parte dos jogos é muito importante no
início da vida dos nossos homens em
angola mas vai perdendo importância a
bíblia
vamos envelhecendo o mesmo acontece
também com o desenvolvimento pessoal mas
não de uma forma tão pronunciada a outra
dimensão que faltou que é a dimensão do
trabalho do negócio é assim tem uma
importância cada vez maior na vida dos
homens que nós tirarmos sendo que depois
dos 50 anos e se aproxima do xi 30% das
mulheres a dicotomia entre a família eo
negócio é muito mais evidente
tem muito mais esta questão é esta este
problema é para resolver entre a família
eo trabalho da família o trabalho nas
mesmas quando são novas têm uma
importância bastante aproximada mas à
medida que as mulheres envelhecem aqui
em angola é a prioridade da família e do
trabalho vão se afastar
o trabalho continua a mexer até aos 50
anos e depois quebra essa família
crescendo e tem uma dimensão muito
acentuada já já
an é próximos 50 anos
a espiritualidade da comunidade eo lazer
para as nossas mulheres têm um
comportamento semelhante ao dos homens
curiosamente uma forma contra intuitiva
também para mim próprio quando vi os
resultados
a espiritualidade tem uma importância
cada vez menor para as nossas mulheres à
medida que os anos vão passar a creche
um pouco a partir dos 50 anos
mexe e é uma dimensão que vai perdendo a
sua importância o lazer ia com mirado
tem uma importância constante ao longo
do tempo
outras dimensões analisadas o fitness e
desenvolvimento pessoal ao longo da vida
das mulheres é algo que é para as
mulheres deixa de ser tão importante
também ao longo da ao longo da vida vai
perdendo sua importância
a conclusão é que o estudo revelou
importância de cristiano do espírito irá
à medida que nós envelhecemos quer para
homens quanto para mulheres
a espiritualidade é cada vez menos
importante ea família cada vez mais
importante
mas fizemos uma outra questão que para
além da importância que estas dimensões
está em qual é o tempo e atenção nós que
efetivamente diz dedicamos a cada uma
delas
porque uma coisa é ser importantes a
outra coisa nós temos que dedicar
efetivamente tempo e era parte dos
homens
nós verificamos que o negócio consome
ainda com o negócio o trabalho consome
ainda bastante temos aos homens tempo
depois lhes falta para a família e para
a parte espiritual detalhados um pouco
mais para os homens a partir dos 35 anos
aqui em angola e isso
revelamos uma diferença ainda maior
entre importância que o trabalho tem
para as pessoas eo tempo que
efetivamente lhe dedicam
já na parte das mulheres aconteça algo
semelhante mas de uma forma mais
pronunciada entre as nossas mulheres as
nossas mulheres falta de tempo sobretudo
para a família mas também pra casa pra
parte espiritual para a comunidade e
para oficinas e este tempo essa
dedicação efetiva e consumiram
essencialmente pelo trabalho acima dos
35 anos
essa dicotomia fica mais evidente para
as nossas mulheres na qual o trabalho
tem uma importância de 26 anos e é o
tempo que efetivamente lhe dedicam tem
32% conclusão entre homens e mulheres
aqui e destas duas mil e sem respostas
que é uma uma mostra bastante grande
universo que entendemos dever quer
provas quer para a mulher se existe uma
dificuldade de realização pessoal na
parte da família na parte do fitas tanto
do do desporto e da sua saúde e na parte
também espiritual as pessoas
provavelmente não sentem são realizadas
na parte espiritual como desviariam esta
é é uma dimensão pessoal mas para a
nossa realização pessoal é importante
nós sentimos realizados também com um
grupo dentro das organizações em que
estamos inseridos e por organizações nós
não nos limitarmos a pensar em empresas
temos que pensar também em clubes
recreativos em clubes desportivos em
organizações religiosas portanto é
qualquer equipa o grupo organização na
qual nós estamos inseridos e para nos
sentimos realizados
não basta questão dos benefícios e estão
desde
pressões é importante nós sentimos que
temos um papel ativo no dentro destas
organizações
e esse sentimento resulta do cruzamento
entre dois acho que é segurança
psicológica eo auto bild
local clube à elite em inglês significa
responsabilidade
já vou falar um pouco sobre isso para de
segurança psicológica é algo é um
conceito muito importante porque
significa segurança nós sentimos a nossa
volta para conseguirmos duvidar de
pessoas criticar e pôr em causa
convenções e regras e idéias
preconcebidas e presta lusíadas
nem sempre os fiéis têm razão e nem
sempre aquilo que está convencionado
dentro das organizações têm razão e
muitas vezes nós sentimos presos
o nosso status ou a nossa terra era o a
nossa autoestima e não queremos entrar
em confronto dentro das organizações com
medo de ser severamente julgados e
enquanto falávamos do erro nas
organizações por corroer nós aprendemos
as minhas equipas são aquelas que eram
mais vezes são aquelas que observa que o
e resistir e conseguem aprender com isso
tanto na parte de segurança psicológica
traz o erro
traz estas questões por cima da mesa
para nós temos o à vontade para falarmos
sobre isso e faz com que conseguimos
influenciados positivamente as nossas
culturas e as nossas estratégias para
atingirmos os objetivos sejam eles quais
forem
a parte do locaute billiton é um termo
em inglês que significa responsabilidade
mas também em 3d no windows nossas
organizações
nós quando cruzamos estes dois segmentos
nós encontramos quatro machos na qual
conseguimos
o carro as nossas pessoas e no estudo
que fizemos
também questionamos as pessoas isto
demonstrou que uma vez como é que as
pessoas sentem em termos de segurança
psicológica para dizer ou pensar dentro
das organizações igual é o inglês ea
responsabilidade que as pessoas sentem
dentro das organizações em que estão
inscritos
quando existem ou vários níveis de
segurança psicológica dia cauã teve o
limite nós temos as pessoas as zonas de
aprendizagem e onde ele está
por outro lado quando temos baixos
níveis de segurança psicológica mas o
elevado em três com a organização nós
temos naquilo deixava uma zona da
ansiedade que eu não tremo estado
nós queremos cuidar das organizações não
estamos anciosos preocupante porque não
conseguimos dizer aquilo pensarmos que
temos que sair
temos que sair serão julgados nosso e
nas nossas entrevistas detalhes que 72%
das nossas pessoas encontrou seis horas
de aprendizagem tanto estão com elevados
níveis de segurança psicológica em
vários níveis de responsabilidade e
temos 21 cento das pessoas em zona de
ansiedade é que ele o objetivo ea
mensagem que vos queria transmitir é que
nós devemos ver quais são as diferentes
dimensões da nossa vira o que é
importante para nós
falar com as pessoas que nos são
próximas sobre isso e ver o que é
importante também para elas perguntar às
pessoas e tentar perceber los e tentar
perceber que havia muito tempo
rosa e nós estamos constantemente a
mudar aquilo tempo tanto para nós hoje
pode não ser importante a 10 anos e as
pessoas efetivamente mudam e quando nós
dizemos às pessoas que elas mudaram tudo
mudar isto não era assim era da urp
existe esse processo de transformação
esse processo de transformação também
existem as organizações
é importante todos nós criamos a apontar
estes de segurança psicológica a em que
as nossas pessoas possam progredir e
sentir se à vontade para falar sobre os
erros e para criar uns organizações
melhores nestes brincava obrigado a
todos
[Aplausos]